getting into God bomb this basically
brings the end of gore the God butcher
this was kind of like the the
self-contained story and that was a cool
thing I mean I imagine that you know
with Jason Aaron when he was writing the
story it was all designed to be one
great big cohesive thing I mean once the
time comes when Jason Aaron you know
when Marvel announces the Jason Aaron is
now leaving forward you'll literally be
able to pick up with God butcher and
just read all the way up to where where
he stops it'll just be one cohesive
story and I have and I will continue to
say that this is the greatest run of
Thor that there's ever been like I can
I've read so many runs of Thor I've read
Matt Fraction I've read Straczynski I've
read Walt Simonson and to me I sit down
and I say this is the best run there's
ever been I mean all the other ones are
great they're fun they're interesting I
like them but in terms of development in
terms of storytelling in terms of
expansion in terms of the art and how
gorgeousness is the greatest running
forward that I think there has ever been
and so picking up in the last video you
know we basically talked about the idea
that Gore the god butcher had
essentially jumped to the future after
grabbing a heart really the heart of the
first elder god this essentially fueled
his power now keep in mind as Gore kills
gods and you know takes their blood
whatever the case may be he expands his
own powers and so in the future he's
become really the most powerful being in
existence flung the the traditional
pantheon of gods I mean keep in mind if
I de Living Tribunal showed up and was
like okay you basically disrupted the
balance of all things
lovely tribunal just phase them out of
existence eternity could destroy you
know gore the god butcher I mean there's
a litany of ways that like Jason Aaron
can end this they wouldn't be fun but he
can in them in a whole litany of waste
but the idea here is that we initially
pick up with a really I guess with
modern-day Thor and King Thor now this
is where things are going to get a lot
more streamlined than they were because
in God butcher we were following three
eras of Thor in this story we are but
they're all in the same place so it's
not like we're jumping through the past
present in the future and trying to
confine it into a story and make it make
sense instead uh we are basically just
kind of covering all different versions
of these four in the same point in time
so we'll still call them like young Thor
yes I guess you know past Thor and
modern Thor and King Thor but the fact
remains here that with modern Thor and
King Thor meeting together some of the
questions we have are answered to a
degree one of the things that he
basically states is that in this era
that about nine
years before this current moment Gore
had just shown up on Asgard and invaded
as god proper and in doing so he had
essentially taken all the Asgardians
prisoner with the exception of Thor
himself
Thor was forced to basically stay on
Asgard and just fend off against wave
after wave after wave of the black
berserkers of gore now this begs the
question what happened to own now when
it comes to the character of Odin we
have what's called Ragnarok Ragnarok and
we'll talk more about this once we
actually get to like the Ragnarok story
Ragnarok is basically the end times of
Asgard it is the apocalypse of Asgard
but what Thor had learned and what we as
the reader had learned was that Ragnarok
was a constantly repeating cycle that to
the Asgardians to their mind you would
eventually have sir - who would kill
Odin Loki would launch a war against
Asgard he would invade he would conquer
Asgard Thor would be killed and then
eventually be as Guardians would be
killed and that would be yet everybody
in house guard would effectively just
die like that would be you know they
died in some grandiose battle but they
would all end up dying what we learned
was that there was this group called the
ones who sit above in shadow who have
been feeding on this cycle and so we're
you know we're thorn looks at the modern
day and says this is the only life that
I have in reality he's been repeating
his life over and over and over again he
just didn't know it and the ones who sit
above in shadow were feeding on this
perpetual cycle of Ragnarok now
eventually Odin figured out what was
going on and instead of Thor just
staying in Asgard Odin basically cashed
Thor out it's one of the reasons why he
banished him and then confined him to
earth so that he would be raised on
earth and would eventually you know come
across this path that would lead to the
death of Odin and Thor would have the
reason to ask what's going on here
because by his own involvement with
Captain America and Iron Man different
things like that he would see the world
through the perspective of a human which
in turn would create curiosity and in
his curiosity he would want to know
what's going on with Ragnarok how does
it work and how do I stop it from
happening and so again it's really kind
of a cool scenario which was on how that
unfolds we'll get into a far more
in-depth explanation of Ragnarok once we
get away onto that story with the
release of Thor 3 but the fact remains
here that because of the fact that Thor
knows what Ragnarok is because he's
aware of Ragnarok so does King Thor
since he's basically Thor in the future
and so the idea here is that in his mind
Odin has effectively just died somewhere
along the Loch that's really what it is
I mean Odin is basically just kind of
moved
and Thor has what's called the Thor
force now the Thor force and the
odinforce those are just names given to
whoever it is that's reeling that
particular power the odinforce is just
an insane amount of energy that Odin has
and it allows him to do whatever it is
that he wants to do at any particular
point in time it's a plot device when
Odin dies that power passes to Thor and
it becomes the Thor force likewise it
could be that both Odin and Thor die and
the power would pass to Loki and it
would become the Loki force it's just
whoever it is this wielding that power
at any particular point in time but the
fact remains that King Thor has the it
has the Thor force the difference does
that remember the Thor force is like a
battery so anybody who wields it long
enough if they do not go into the
odinsleep or the Thor sleep in this case
they were just basically run out of
power and that's really what it is he's
been fighting for so long and he's
exhausted so much energy he can't go
into the to the for sleep he can't rest
otherwise you know there wouldn't be
anybody to defend a scar and so the
result is that his power is effectively
almost completely defeated now with the
arrival of modern Thor what this does is
it rekindles hope it reach indels the
possibility that he may yet live it
reach him was a possibility that Asgard
could very well be saved at the same
time modern Thor and future Thor are
joined by past authority and the reason
why is because of the fact the past Thor
basically has this dream where he
realizes that Gore the god butcher isn't
dead when he Pelias believed previously
believed he had killed him one of course
black berserkers kind of throws like
this Cronus charge Adam or something
like that anyway just time displaces him
and it teleports into the future that's
really all it is
of course he rises up through the pond
the difference here is that he does not
immediately join a modern and future
Thor instead he's actually forced into
being a subject he's forced into being a
slave now the reason for this is twofold
the first half is that in the mind of
Gore he's captured so many gods already
and it's how it is so extreme he's not
worried about modern or future Thor now
that will be the really the source of
his undoing
and that's just humorous the other half
of this is that because Thor is so
strong and because Thor is so capable
and because he is the one that almost
killed Gore capturing Thor is really
more of like a trophy than anything else
you know I finally captured the guy who
almost killed me
you know it's basically more kind of
solidifying in his own mind that he is
indeed the god of God so to speak that
he's the one person that's going to
bring everything crashing down and so
with this in mind what King Thor tells
modern Thor
is that again where where Gore had
basically showed up on Asgard kids
tattooed all the Asgardians those who
fought against Gore had basically been
killed and those who have been captured
have been whisked off to a planet on the
far side of the universe where Gore is
building a god bomb a bomb is designed
to eliminate all God's we follow King
Thor and modern Thor over to the
location of where Gore's hanging out at
now getting a little bit more into this
whole idea of a of a god bomb what we
end up finding out is that Gore is not
entirely wrong now for those of you guys
who are reading unworthy Thor this is
why Jason Aaron's run is so important
this is why Jason Aaron's run is so
significant there's a conversation that
happens between gore and his son we
don't really know where his son came
from we don't know why he's there but
there's a conversation that happens
between the two of them and what Gore
says is that in his mind gods are
inherently evil gods are inherently bad
gods you know answer the prayers of
their followers based on a win they may
choose not to answer they may choose to
answer it's just kind of doing whatever
they want to do when they do it and how
they do it and so on so forth and so
because of that Gore wants to eliminate
them all the purpose of the god bomb is
to essentially detonate the bomb so that
when it goes off it will kill all gods
throughout the time straight gods from
the present gods from the from the past
gods from the future those who may have
been hidden away from Gore they just
didn't know about and never caught and
killed those who were never caught in
capture whatever the case may be they
will die all throughout the timestream
now notice the motivation of gore with
this mindset gore is basically then
passing this information on to his son
and so when Gore's son speaks directly
with Thor who's basically working as a
prisoner Gore's son basically says look
what this is going to do is this going
to usher in a great era it's going to
usher in an era where people don't fight
over which gods real and which gods
false people won't fight over which gods
right and which God is wrong people will
not live their lives waiting for an
eternity of splendor or fearing an
eternity of hell people will live in the
moment they will value what they have
they will recognize this life is the
only life they have and they will treat
it that way they will take the most
advantage out of it that's not wrong and
that's the coolest thing about that is
because that's what Nick Fury was saying
when he whispered to Odin son and he
said Gore was right and it made him
unworthy it was the hammer realizing
that's true like its true like people
you know people like Ford they represent
the ideology that people don't value the
life they have they value the life they
hope they have and so again it's
basically nil never really living in the
moment that's why Jane Foster was chosen
because she's literally a person dying
of cancer every moment could be her last
and so she values what she has left of
her life because for her she doesn't
view the possibility of an afterlife she
doesn't hear the possibility of going to
heaven she views the life that she has
as being the only one she has and she
looks to make the most of it she's
living in the present not living in the
future that's why the hammer chose her
and that's why it's so cool that's why
all this wraps around and creates one
great big cohesive story because you get
a little piece here and you get a little
piece there and then you get a little
piece over there somewhere and then it
all comes together to create this
amazing cohesive story where everything
is important and that's why I love it so
much as wives it's such a cool thing now
for here we are introduced to the
granddaughters of King Thor and this is
really kind of cool because these chicks
they do not play like they are they are
hardcore but the funny thing about this
is that while they are being forced to
work in subservience which is to say to
basically help build this god bomb at
the end of the day they're also planning
a way to get out and the funny thing is
that with past Thor being so young being
so brash being so reckless showing up
here having been captured and saying
well we have to fight we have to find we
have to win we have to get our freedom
he's not thinking rationally he's not
thinking according to a plan and that's
really what Jason Aaron is hitting on
when it comes to these different
iterations of Thor and that's something
that I hope you noticed - Thor is young
I mean he's young he's brash let's just
battle you know when it comes to modern
day for modern day Thor is a little more
reasonable he's a little more thinking
he's still quick to fight he's still
quick to battle but King Thor is old
he's wise it is basically the steps of
Thor as he becomes essentially Odin as
he eventually gets to the point where he
realizes that sometimes you can't just
fight directly sometimes you need a plan
sometimes you have to function
accordingly sometimes you just have to
be intelligent about what you do so it's
really kind of cool to see these
different iterations coming together but
of course with young Thor he's basically
told look you know get back to work keep
your mouth shut do not draw attention to
us and the reason why is because picking
up later that night what the the
granddaughters of King Thor we
ultimately find that what they've done
is they basically instructed a bomb of
their own and the reason why is because
of the fact that in three days the god
bomb will be finished and every God
everywhere in existence will be
destroyed
when that happens all things will
essentially come crashing down including
all of them there and so the goal is to
basically destroy this god bomb before
it can go off now of course the funny
thing about this and this is really when
like the brash nature of young Thor
comes into the equation when you simply
just grab the bomb and races off it
races off with a god bomb with the
intention of destroying it now things
get a little bit murky at this point and
I would imagine Jason there and kind of
fast track's things a bit and the reason
why is because of the fact that where
the bomb is detonated we immediately
transition over to King Thor and modern
Thor whether facing off against some of
these these Gazeta basically being years
like these shark gods that are being
used as kind of like guards of the
planet of gore and then there's suddenly
met with the arrival of young Thor we
don't know how he got there we don't
know you know if he was just teleported
if the god bomb went off and he was just
suddenly moved away we're not really
sure exactly why it is that he's here we
just know that he is but alongside
modern Thor and alongside King Thor what
they basically say is we have to destroy
Gore we have to kill him so that we can
make sure that all God's everywhere
survive so we effectively have three
different Thor's fighting in the same
battle and it is a sight to behold now
from here we get into the downfall of
Gore and this is one of the greatest
things about this with Jason Aaron's
storytelling he does not take a
conventional approach with ending
stories which is to say hey guys here's
a really cool event and it's done it
doesn't go that way with Jason Aaron
Jason Aaron really kind of builds up he
builds characters up and then he gives
them a gradual downfall and it's usually
an ironic downfall against the the force
of three Thor's gore cannot pull it off
and what Jason Aaron is this was saying
here is that Thor is unique among all
the gods that are in existence because
of his desire for battle because of his
desire for conflict because he's so
capable at what he does
he cannot simply just be defeated like
any sort of God when you have three of
them they are non-stop abode and so gore
literally throws every single thing he
has with him he kills other gods that
are currently a slaves to absorb their
power and increase his own and he still
can't pull it off initially and so what
we end up having is all three of these
gods racing into Gore engaging in this
massive battle which leads into them
basically kind of being I guess
catapulted into the Sun now this is kind
of cool actually this is pretty damn
amazing to be honest with
and the reason why is because of the
fact we dealt with three Thor's facing
off against court we would expect him to
win right like we would expect him to
take today only for Gore to deal for the
battle to end for all three Thor's to
come crashing back to earth and for Gore
to have been the one that came out
triumphant and so what Jason Aaron does
is he gives us this amazing crescendo
it's almost like this this feeling that
all hope is lost that Gore has managed
to defeat three fours and they all have
an incredible endurance fighting prowess
the whole nine yards and gore still wins
and so again it's a very terrifying
situation but what we end up doing is we
pick up with the wipe of gore when she
basically begins to do kind of talking
to her husband now this is where the
downfall comes into play and the reason
why I say that is because of the fact
that she says look you know I look
forward to an era when the god bomb is
detonated I look forward to an era when
there are no more gods out there when
there are no more people to worship you
know and she's presses her affection by
basically referring to him and saying
you are my god in return gore kills her
and that's where the downfall comes into
play and the reason why is because of
the fact that the entire scenario is
observed by the son of gore now what
does some plays along and says look you
know yes I can't wait for this bomb to
go off yada yada yada you know we'll get
everything set up and going at the end
of the day he intends to kill his father
because his father killed his mother and
so again it's so cool because usually
whenever it comes to like dystopian
rulers or like totalitarians or
something like that the one thing they
fear is someone rising up I need to
becoming a martyr or mustering all the
forces together and just outright
bringing them down it's the one thing
that Gore fears above all others he
fears someone rising up with enough
power to bring him crashing down and
it's that way with every single
narrative when there's someone with
absolute power now it doesn't mean that
they are successfully defeated but it
does mean that it is one thing that they
fear and so by going through and you
know basically charging up this god bomb
with one of the Thor's who's remain
captured by Gore as well as the other
two Thor's you know trying to climb back
into battle arming up mountainsides from
wherever wasn't they landed the modern
Thor is basically rescued by the son of
Gore and the son of war says look my
father killed my mother I will help you
defeat my father now the reason why this
is so cool is because the son of war
represents what Gore used to be in the
origin story of gore Gore used to be a
guy where he was basically just trying
to live
life I mean he had a wife he had he had
children of his own he was very mortal
he was very emotional dare I say very
human in terms of how he existed it was
only after he lost everything that he
became so dark and he became so bleak
but his son is still who Gor used to be
his son still cares about others his son
still feels loved still feels emotion
still feels affection and so because of
that in his anger in his wrath and in
his desire for revenge he takes his side
against his father in doing this it
grants a reprieve for all three Thor's
to rebandage and begin the process of
waging a war against Gore trying to
bring him down now this is where things
get incredibly cool because as each one
begins to take on Gork each one of them
begins to meet their defeat and
ultimately it comes down to the
modern-day version of Thor who picks up
both his hammer and the hammer of King
Thor now this is something that we've
almost never seen before I don't think
I've ever seen an instance when we've
had a Thor wield two hammers at the same
time now this is crazy because the power
of the hammers has always been filling
us a little bit ambiguous and even then
when this story was written the power
behind the hammers had not been
explained by Jason Aaron now we know now
that is just like this sentient cosmic
storm it's basically cosmic energy
inside this hammer that's been harnessed
by Odin so that Thor can use it having
two hammers composed of cosmic energy it
creates a level of power hitherto
unrivaled and so what this does the Thor
essentially smashing them together it
allows him to both destroy the god bomb
before it kills any of the other gods
across all time and space as well as
absorb the necro sword now what this
does is it basically transforms Thor
into the god of gods because we now have
four really the all black Metro sword a
weapon designed to do nothing more than
kill gods and destroy worlds as well as
wielding two hammers this is probably
the single greatest picture that I've
ever seen in my life
when it comes to Thor he looks so badass
with this with his old this whole getup
he's just like cloud and black with two
hammers I mean it's one of the coolest
things that I've ever seen but but Gork
has essentially lost the source of his
power
that's really what it is he has no power
left there's nothing left coming to him
he is effectively as mortal as he was in
his origin story and so because of this
because of the fact that Gore's
and defeated his son appears to him and
says look I am a source of your defeat
but what we also end up learning is that
his son is not actually his son instead
his son was a Comstock created by the
necro sword so again this is really kind
of an interesting scenario because what
it does is it shows us that beep in his
core once you get past his whole desire
to kill gods gore was still very much
you know human so to speak in the sense
that he wanted offspring he wanted a
life but it also shows us that he was
not just inherently evil he may have
lost his way he may have fallen down the
wrong path but at the end of the day his
motivation was to basically create a
world or a universe a reality without
gods because in his mind the gods were
the source of all suffering that existed
out there and so eventually question how
many civilizations have suffered how
many people have died across the
universe because the gods did not answer
their call again rolling back into the
idea of why the hammer chose Jane Foster
to be worthy instead of allowing Odin
son to be worthy so again it's a
beautiful story that all kind of comes
together and you know really becomes
cohesive but in these final moments
Gore's effectively defeated by being
decapitated that's really about it
I mean from there there's really nothing
more that goes on with this character
that's pretty much the end of him and so
what this does is it gives us kind of a
really cool epilogue in the sense that
we pick up about three days later after
this battle and since that Asgard has
turned into this sort of beacon and home
for gods across the cosmos that all gods
from all these different races are all
kind of coming back door arriving on
Asgard it's going to serve as a major
hub of course what's left of the
Asgardians still reside there we don't
know explicitly what role that you know
Asgard will play in the future at least
not yet but at this moment we just sort
of pick up with the idea that everybody
is living out the rest of their lives
you know that the past or that modern
Thor are sent back to their own times
respectively a King Thor stays in the
future and and that's really yet I mean
it's really the idea they just kind of
go back to doing what they were doing
before but what this does is it sets the
stage for the arrival of Galactus on
earth and it actually sets the stage for
old King Thor vs Galactus and the
question of what it is that happen to
earth in this reality but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you